thank you yaser and I have with me the
hero of the day Ray Robson Ray
congratulations what a game it was
against ala but to tell you the truth it
felt like he gave you everything you
wanted when you play with white pieces
right you could push your pawns you put
your knight on C6 like how did it feel
for you um yeah well it was definitely
very double-edged I mean it optically it
looks great for white with all the space
but I think this is actually just like
the start of theory so I actually
couldn't remember after Knight C6 if he
played Queen E8 somehow during the game
I was thinking is it Queen D7 maybe
maybe it was Queen E8 since he played it
and this line with like Bishop A6 Bishop
C5 BC Queen D2 I thought this was like
just the start of a line which is very
double-edged the engine probably says
white has some Advantage but practically
it can go either way so I mean I was
happy but uh still not so happy yes I
mean it's still it was the start for you
something which looks quite new for me
sometimes looks very diff move on number
14 so let's say when do you think things
start started to go your way in this
game um well so I played this move
Bishop
F3 um and now I'm preparing to play
probably just G5 and he played
H6 and um I think this was probably
based on a
miscalculation so when he played H6 I
was first trying to figure out what's
wrong if I just go G5 um trying to
figure out what the point of H6 is and I
didn't think Knight H7 would be good
because I can just play H4 Bishop G4 H4
like I did in the game and his Knight
just became very passive and I'm just
pushing on the king side very simply so
I thought he must want to do something
with taking an H3 and then I saw maybe
there's this idea take and take and now
the point is if I take here he has uh
Bishop H6 um but maybe maybe he just
missed I think I have Bishop G2 here and
then if he moves let's say his Queen
along the h f to keep the bishop H6 idea
alive then I have Rook H1 first and then
I can always take so I think there was
something else instead oop sorry I went
all this way yes I think somewhere here
maybe not Queen H5 maybe there was
something better like Queen uh Queen G3
or something like that Queen G3 que G
yes six and then it's a very crazy
situation yes that somehow computer
likes this position so much and all of
us we were shocked because I mean it's
not like direct way to win but Rook on
E1 is hanging and this bishop g5a yeah
so I thought I can play just move the
king or something que I don't have then
there is a rook on ah yeah I didn't
realize my E1 Rook is thing I thought I
can just s side step with the king and
queen C2 but okay oh yeah this is
computer line of course I mean Peter
swiler was showing during the show and I
was just wondering how far did you
calculate I mean it's so almost
impossible I think to find it over the
board and I think that's why he actually
thought maybe to play Queen H3 but maybe
decided to play Knight H7
instead yeah I mean I saw basically all
this idea but I thought I can always
just move the king and queen I didn't
realize my Rook on E1 was saying I even
saw so in this position yes I saw this
to try to block with Knight H5 if I take
but then there's even like even this
maybe it's possible Rook H1 and his
Queen is trapped oh nice and it's just
completely so Queen is
trapped well looks nice but yeah after
Knight H7 Bishop G4 and H4 I mean this
position's like very critical already
like borderline losing it felt like
during the game because he has to do
something immediate otherwise I'm just
running over him probably with F5 so he
tried to close things with H5 and now if
I go Bishop F3 he maybe has Bishop C8 um
Knight B5 Queen D7 so he's trying to
stop F5 so on Bishop H3 F5 um look
looked like desperate attempt you know
to do something yeah he's trying to
close things if my Bishop were on F3
here I could play Rook E6 uh but now my
Knight's unprotected so I thought I can
just go for this like direct attack even
though it was kind of nice like his
pieces were kind of all trapped so I
wasn't sure but the attack just felt U
very difficult to play against so I just
went for this and basically Rook G1
Bishop B6 yeah the p is just coming okay
apparently he can still fight but but I
think during the game it was very hard
to put up like good resistance here yeah
are you happy with the day today how how
how it went and how is it how it going
at the moment uh yeah I mean I'm I'm
pretty happy I there's always chances
well chances to do worse and chances to
do better I think in my first game
against Anish at first I was um trying
to defend a bit and then at the end of
the game I think I actually should have
definitely played on I had no risk and
there actually was good chances to win
if I I just continued the game but draw
was fine and then the second game
against Fabby he was trying to beat me
from a worse position because I had was
playing on the increment for like the
whole game so I think I also had some
chances to maybe win that game but then
when I I blundered something he he was
probably winning later on so uh in the
end I was happy to at least make a draw
and obviously this this was definitely
my best game of the day yeah so actually
you have plus two right now and you're
leading in the tournament like have you
realized did I mean because Liam just
lost the game I didn't realize it but
then someone told me after the game that
oh Liam lost when I release so yeah I
don't know not very expected but um yeah
I mean it's the best position to be in
so I guess I should be happy about it
yeah absolutely thank you so much for
your um comments and see you tomorrow
hopefully all the best of luck thank you
and we're back to the studio thank you
Anastasia and thank you Ray